In Morocco, at least seven people were killed and dozens injured...
...after a train derailed near the capital, Rabat.
In Saudi Arabia, US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo met with Saudi King Salman...
...and Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman...
...to talk about the disappearance two weeks ago of Saudi journalist Jamal Khashoggi.
In France, President Emmanuel Macron named Christophe Castaner as interior minister.
Castaner was the junior minister formerly in charge of relations with Parliament.
In India, protests and clashes broke out in Srinagar...
...during local council elections in India-controlled Kashmir.
Less than four percent of eligible voters went to the polls.
Finally from Nigeria, a medical aid worker held hostage in Nigeria since March...
...was killed by Islamist militants following the expiration of a deadline.